another date with destiny for Tereza may
another defeat today only the fourth
worst in history after the very worst
only two months ago any other prime
minister would be finished and indeed
this might yet be the beginning of the
end for her Premiership perhaps more
significantly even the beginning of the
end for brexit itself MPs will vote on
an article 50 extension on Thursday with
a vote beforehand on Wednesday on No
Deal highly likely to be rejected the
government has offered a free vote for
those where they will not tell Tory MPs
how to vote an almost unprecedented step
for something so important so unsure are
they of their ability to command their
troops many MPs think it's indicative of
a government whose authority has added
away we have to in my view stick to
things like our manifesto commitment
which was to leave no deal on the table
until the last minute and noted is
better than a bad deal so of course I am
slightly sort of perplexed that we have
decided to give tomorrow as a free vote
I never mind her MPs there are some who
think that even her cabinet might revolt
I have said already but I think if she
lost tonight and then potentially loses
as in Parliament's or starts to
dismantle the strategy that she has used
I think that does make her position very
very difficult and that's presume your
conversation this year in the cabinet we
want to have most MPs think an extension
of article 50 is now highly likely and
probably one longer rather than shorter
I think long actually a very short post
Berman just for technical reasons to put
through their dear I think we we lost
that tonight the question is will it
even be permitted
Donald tough the presidents of the EU
Council said tonight should there be a
UK reason request for an extension the
eu-27 will consider it and decide by
unanimity the eu-27 will expect a
credible justification for a possible
extension and its curation the smooth
functioning of the EU institutions will
need to be ensured I'm one of Labour
many thought defeat tonight with signal
of full embrace of a second referendum
for the party that doesn't seem so sure
Labour's priority remains our
alternative exits deal that has a strong
and close economic relationship with the
European Union Parliament has seldom
seen such paralysis so rarely had so few
within it with so little idea of what
happens next a prime minister with no
voice a leader of the opposition with
apparently so little new to say a
government which is in retreat from the
battlefield and all of this just over
two weeks before Britain is due to
experience the biggest political
constitutional and economic change we've
seen for nearly half a century a night
then full of ironies Breck stirs votes
probably keeping us in the EU for longer
irony to the Parliament wielded so much
power in the face of a prime minister
with so little but has no idea what to
do with it
Lewis could all Sky News Westminster